my friends paula abdul and randy jackson
are back on the show
so i thought i would celebrate with a
game of
most likely to but i can only pick
former american idol contestants or
judges for my answers um advanced
warning this was
a long time ago for me like 18 years
[Music]
so
which contestant takes the longest in
the bathroom to get ready
i don't really remember here's the thing
about my season of idol
i don't know that everybody knows we we
were paired together in
rooms and in this house we all stayed in
a house
i ended up just taking myself and going
because i know i don't know if it was
christina or tamyra i roomed with them i
think and i
one of them did yoga like really early
or
hours was just different and i was like
whoa that's interesting
and and i remember i slept on the couch
because i'm a night owl
and so you know i know that one of them
wasn't and i didn't want to bother them
um so i slept on the couch like right in
front like next to the pool table
i think that's where i slept mostly
in that house
[Music]
[Applause]
um which judge is most likely to tell
you there's food in your teeth
oh hands down that's paula she's like a
girlfriend like a girl's girl like she's
she'd be like whoa you need to figure
that out like she'd she'd be helpful
she would not let you walk around look
like an idiot she's a sweetheart
okay which judge is most likely to have
a ferret as a pet
i really want to say simon
i just really think it would be cool if
simon had a ferret named garfunkel
i just think it'd be fine because seven
and garfunkel
i don't know anyway there's an idea
simon you're welcome for the family the
future family pet
which contestant is most likely to
become president
well i know that the only one i know
that's actually been involved in
politics is clay aiken
but i don't know he's pretty opinionated
that's the thing i love about clay you
know exactly who he is
um right off the bat he doesn't hide
anything i don't know
for some reason i want to say christina
christian for my
for my season of idol she was always so
like
well spoken and thought out with her
answers
like knew what she wanted and was bold
about it but like in a very i don't know
i felt like she was very diplomatic
[Music]
which judge is most likely to be a
stand-up comedian
i don't know i feel like paula would
make us laugh y'all
i don't even know if she she's funny but
i also think like she would do things
that would just
you'd laugh at as long as with you know
as well as with
um she's just entertaining like the
things that come out of her mouth
randy you just i don't know if it's
standard queenie you just want to you
know drink with them
you just want to like hang with them you
know what though i would love to go with
randy to
watch a comedian i think he'd be fun
he'd be a fun hank
uh which judge is most likely to attend
a kelly clarkson concert
randy and paula i feel like that would
be like a friend date they'd like go on
too like i'd be like i'm in town and
they'd come
you know and see the show or whatever um
i feel like simon's always like way too
busy like he's
i feel like he's got like as many jobs
as i do um but um
well now simon and rainey have another
job too on their plate so i don't know
no one's coming to my show because no
one's doing shows because live concerts
are a time
you know in history books at this point
remember live shows when people came
together in a room
without masks or ppe it's fine anyway
i have to go i have to go shoot a show i
love my idol days
i know a lot of people back in the day
always used to say all of us tried to
separate ourselves from the show
i can't speak for everybody else but i
didn't i loved i loved it it was like
camp
and we had a lot of fun we were
exhausted but it was a really
good experience and i don't think i'll
ever work
that hard in my life and i have a lot of
jobs right now and i'm a mom and i'm
still saying
it was like no sleep in all work and
thank you for that
prep for the industry thank you
[Music]
you